johnny depp he's back in a london
courtroom fighting for what seems like
is his career we spoke to many folks
inside the industry including a major
studio head who called depp
radioactive depp has incurred
massive hits to his reputation many of
which are his own making
here's the new headline inside johnny
depp's self-made implosion
the hollywood reporter details what led
to a career downfall
culminating in that dramatic fantastic
beasts exit
i do not fight out of hatred johnny had
actually only done a day's filming
i think on his own the least important
thing to me
is becoming famous and being well known
and
you know trying to be everybody's hero
et's been with johnny long before he
became one of hollywood's most bankable
stars
over just the last two decades def's
films have earned more than 10
billion at the box office his next movie
out in february
minamata paid him just 3 million and in
court this summer
johnny testified he's 100 million in
debt
so what happened johnny's volatile
antics reportedly turned him into a
liability on set
one altercation with his now ex amber
heard during filming
of the last pirates of the caribbean
left him injured shutting down
production for two weeks
at a cost of 350 thousand dollars a day
a hollywood studio can shoulder the cost
of maybe
shutting down a production for one day
what they can't do
is they can't count on an individual
to really sell the film with such a
tarnished reputation
then there's his court drama which
johnny's still fighting
johnny was hitting me and he was hitting
me
hard and repeatedly depp is now filed an
appeal after losing his so-called
wife-beater libel case
his grounds for appeal aren't clear but
it's not dep's only court battle
johnny and amber go to trial next year
in his defamation case against her